[Music]
alright this of course a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
now so far
hundreds of challengers not one winner
why we don't make mistake yeah we are
the definition of perfection yes okay
and there there silence means they agree
with ya that's the sentence forget that
part
tonight a young fan says he thinks he
caught a mistake on our show I can't
believe the nerve of this name he anyway
he doesn't give his name so I'm just
gonna call him
beard oh all right Berto says the
mistake happened during a recent comedy
bit hi Conan I wanted to mention an
error that I found on a recent episode
of your show so you were talking about
it's BuzzFeed topics and you brought up
five Disney Princesses that you didn't
know we're Scientologists look at this
one five Disney princesses you didn't
know we're Scientologists
oh my god well I hate to tell you but
anesthesia wasn't the Disney Princess
she was actually from a movie made by
the Fox animations - sorry but I found
an error well first of all I think we
found an error here Doe was apparently
about six inches tall because he's in
front of his computer screen
now she's a cute little fella yeah
no beard oh I hate to tell you but you
are dead wrong
Anastasia is a Disney princess you see
she was developed by Disney animators in
1997 but when the movie was done they
decided she just wasn't sweet and pure
enough to be a Disney Princess
so they pawned her off on Fox here's a
clip from the movie you'll see why
Disney dumped her
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've watched that movie a thousand times
anyway the challenge still stands if you
think you've sported an arrow on our
show reporter at team koco.com slash
haha I've found an error we will sort it
out
right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chunk
meat out of the maestro
[Applause]
you